since 2010 the commission of women
victims for victims of poverty has
worked with digital democracy to
leverage technology tools to address
rape and gender-based violence in Haiti
this team launched the 572 women's
Emergency Response call center the call
center provides women and girls who are
victims of violence free access to
information and services a woman can
call in 24 hours a day to report an
incident of rape or domestic violence
and co-lead agents help orient her on
where to get medical legal and
psychosocial services women in
port-au-prince come directly to the
Cobra weave office to complete the human
rights intake process during intake
agents use digital Livescribe pens to
capture the women's account the pen
records a woman's voice in addition to
capturing everything that is written on
the page this technology allows the
agent to maintain eye contact
facilitating a more natural conversation
and avoiding the need for women to
repeat sensitive information the agents
then upload information from a
Livescribe pen which creates an
interactive PDF that syncs the audio and
written accounts this allows agents to
ensure that the written document is
accurate from there they enter all
information from the intake form into a
cloud based database system built on
Drupal kabanov uses a system to generate
comprehensive reports and visualize data
this information allows Kobe beef to
better understand the nature of cases
while strengthening information sharing
with national and international
authorities this veteran forms advocacy
and helps create necessary changes to
improve security and services for women
and girls in Haiti